let's get into that first big story i'm
going to start with this tweet from ryan
james gerdusky
he says georgia gop primary turnout by
year in 2018 608 380. in 2022 1 million
hundred nine thousand five hundred and
six that is
almost double so as i mentioned in the
intro to this show
for those that didn't see it
there's a lot of a lot of ways you can
accomplish that you know i was saying
like destroying the economy is one of
those ways i think that certainly
shocked a bunch of people five dollar a
gallon gasoline is gonna get a lot of
people to the polls but i also think
it's going to get a lot of democrats to
switch and that's a contributing factor
check this out from the atlanta journal
constitution data shows thousands of
democrats voting in gop primary
they say seven percent of georgia voters
who cast a gop ballot
previously pulled a democratic ballot
two years ago
if that's true and you actually go down
and look at the democrat numbers it
looks like democrats dropped by about
seven percent republicans jumped by
about seven percent so it looks like
democrats may have dropped anywhere from
seven to uh ten percent republicans jump
seven percent well they're trying to say
that that's some ploy by the democrats
to make it get the candidates that they
want and all that kind of stuff i mean
that's nonsense it's nonsense the thing
that really matters about this that
you know i live in los angeles
california and people are going to be
liberal there until the world ends it's
going to be an apocalyptic leftist
nightmare forever and so what i think is
important is that
it's about the children i think that
this is the most about the schools
what's happening with the transgender
movement and what's happening with our
education system i think we saw what
happened in virginia and i think that if
we continue on the path as conservatives
hammering on education then we're going
to be able to continue to switch voters
you switch independent voters you switch
democrat voters over to republican and
if you have republicans who come out and
say listen my number one priority is
education my number one priority is your
kids because the left thinks that the
schools own your kids the parents
shouldn't have a say in your kids lives
if conservatives and republicans keep
pushing on that then you you will win
you will switch people over i think it
was might have been james lindsay who
said this that the democrats are turning
parents into a voting block yeah that's
great yeah i mean i'm speaking at all
these rallies all these different things
especially again in california you know
whether they're coveted rallies or
education rallies and i've said this a
thousand times before this is a
revolution of normal people like these
people who come to these rallies they're
not the people who are going to the 2016
trump rallies you know maga and their
hats on and everything with confederate
flags these are parents who just said
i'm fed up with this nonsense i'm going
to i want to change my community that
was true in 2016. yeah i went to a bunch
of these trump rallies i've talked about
it tons of times where the people i met
were like i'm not a republican i've
never voted republican i remember i was
in fort lauderdale and i was talking to
some middle-aged woman and she was so
excited she had her kids and they were
about to watch trump speak and so i was
just asking people covering the rally
like what's your position you know are
you a republican she's like oh no no
i've never voted before she's like wow
no one's ever spoken to me the way trump
has when talking about these issues that
affect my community and i was like wow
so we saw that we saw trump lit up areas
that were just people wouldn't turn out
for right and at the same time the
democratic party i mean they they
basically immolated when they they oh
they they ruined bernie sanders in 2016
with the hillary clinton dnc scandal
where they they colluded essentially
when the emails came out you could find
to to keep him from getting the
nomination and then with again in 2020
when it looked like bernie sanders was
hot and then all of a sudden biden
appears out of nowhere and they put this
near demented guy this 79 year old man
or 78 year old man into office
i i have my faith in that and the
leadership of that party is is gone
compared to where it was 15 20 years ago
and you made a good point about
education that was what i thought at the
top of the show and tim was leading us
in i think that's a big big part of this
is the education is that kids have been
getting put in this these government
facilities and without oversight or
being indoctrinated essentially and it's
people have had it yeah i mean they
should put cameras in all the classrooms
the numbers doubling i mean that's
correct it's almost doubling
the amount of gop turnout that's crazy
isn't it a lot uh covet as well i mean
the way that they handled all the the
covet restrictions that normal people
who wouldn't say oh i'm necessarily
republican are fed up with the way that
they handled that i mean that goes
beyond politics as well i think i i
really do just think all of those things
are an issue but the economy it's the
it's the economy stupid is the famous
quote well they did polls on it yeah
they show the jobs and the economy i
mean i hope that msnbc just keeps
talking about january 6th and
insurrection and all those kind of
things because it doesn't mean anything
to people you know what there's one
thing that did it
the federal reserve no no no there's one
thing that's a jail right one thing all
of you at home
participated in it and you know that one
thing was that caused this big shift
putting those little stickers of joe
biden pointing at gas prices saying i
did that yeah how many regular people
went to the gas pump and they went what
and then they saw joe biden i did that
and then they they he did do that and he
did do that
five bucks yeah i enter on the side of
that the economy was on its way down
anyway with this mass printing of money
since 2008 and obama bailed out fannie
mae and freddie mac but biden shutting
down the pipelines definitely
accelerated the process yeah since the
meeting at jekyll island yeah really
yeah yeah that's so funny i blame
rockefeller yeah
you ever see the time travel meme where
it's like what women it's the what's the
projects like what women would do and
it's like the woman's like i'm your gran
i'm your granddaughter and she's like
wow and then the for the men it's a guy
in full tactical gear
and then we have to stop this meeting
well there's another guy wearing like a
world war one helmet with rifle and it's
like jekyll island 1910 and he's like
trust me trust me great grandfather we
have to do this
if you say so yeah andrew jackson knew
yeah they shot that shot that guy yeah
he broke up like what was it the second
central bank yep yep and then they put
them on the 20s like to slap him in the
face i know the founding fathers since
the beginning have warned us against
central banks and that we should
congress is supposed to control our
money but as listen as much as i think
people who are savvy might understand
there's an issue with the centralized
control of your currency for the average
person they can't see that far right
they can see first layer issues and
problems they can see yo i make 15 bucks
an hour all the democrats claimed that
was a living wage i can't buy gas
and so they're just like make the gas
cheaper don't care yeah that's it
no go ahead yeah i mean you can i'll
give
i mean if if your gas is only going up a
couple cents and maybe it's 20 a month
like i think the people need to take
also some responsibility and say okay if
it's only going up this much a month but
it's not in just the gas i mean we can
talk about gas but it's in every single
facet of our economy because the gas
affects how your how much your food
costs i mean it affects and you have
this this war in ukraine and russia and
everything affects how much the food
costs i mean there's a lot more than
just the price of gas that's affecting
people especially then the new housing
bubble
there's a lot going on i found out why i
haven't gotten starlink yet right so i
ordered starlink a while ago
it is it well partly
it's the so it's the supply chain it's
this it's the silicon chips so the
shortages oh yeah
i say well that's the same with cars
right cars they have special chips that
can like a bmw dealership they have
special chips that only go in their cars
and they're only made in one place yeah
and because of that that it's all shut
down essentially because these supply
chain issues and makes it so that they
can't get these chips for the bmws and
other cars you know you know the price
up yeah elon musk said he was going to
vote republican yeah and i tweeted
democrats should start to ask themselves
why they're losing people
and they don't care the response on
twitter was like rich guy doesn't want
to pay taxes surprise surprise and i'm
like you had a rich guy who just paid
more taxes than anyone anywhere else in
history who was voting for your people
but i think they never cared if you call
people deplorables you surely don't care
how they feel about you yeah yep
that's a that's a really good point so i
i was talking about how during covet joe
biden he would say things like here's
what we have to do and we're going to
lock these things down and i'm like he's
talking about things that red states
aren't doing which means he's clearly
not talking to republicans at all that's
amazing but if you go back to hillary
clinton you know the deplorables
there were there was there's there's
this country has been divided for a long
time it's just been getting worse i
wonder if the real issue is not that the
country is getting more divided but that
we can really see what the other people
think when they tweet it
yeah
or i was thinking like
what's what's
obviously there was chaos under the
table and we've lifted the the sheet now
we see the chaos but is that making it
more chaotic that we can see it or are
we just now aware that it's been chaotic
well i think that i mean going back to
to marx and marcus and the frankfurt
school you'll find that leftism as an
ideology is revolutionary in nature if
you're going to have this ideology be
ruling these people's lives then that's
what they're going to be pushing for and
they will put it under the guise of oh
helpfulness and morality helping
everyone equality they'll put it under
those sort of umbrella terms but really
it's a revolution or an ideology based
on destruction that's what it is
critical theory in essence not just
critical race theory critical gender
theory any of these all it is is
destruction critical theory itself the
original marks marxist ideas is it based
like the idea that you want to kneecap
your opponent metaphorically is that all
based on like you must tear down the
other to acquire their level of equality
well yeah that's marxist and view yeah i
mean that's really what it comes down to
is that other people have something that
you don't and you want to take it from
them to make it equal for everyone i
mean that's from layman's terms but yeah
just greedy people yeah everyone else
who has more than you it's greedy lazy
too that's
the craziest thing to me is like
my view my perspective on the world is
that you are owed nothing
and you deserve nothing
but hope that you will get what you've
worked for and things like that right
you can work as hard as you want and
typically that does lead to success
perseverance does lead to success
there's a possibility you could work
really really hard and then you get
julian assanged you know someone comes
and just screws you over
so i look at like the formula shortage
and there are so many people who are
like why isn't the government providing
for us why isn't the government giving
us these things i see all these memes in
the leftist where there's like the
problem is there's only four companies
that make formula and i'm like and what
if there were zero
it's the craziest thing that you think
the government should intervene because
there aren't enough no we the government
intervening was the problem in the first
place we need market competition to
actually start saying okay we need more
baby formula the problem is the
government shut down everything
government shoved down the world from
covet that's the craziest part i'm
getting really tired of the where's the
government to save me mindset like in
the texas shooting they were like where
were the police and i'm like well they
were outside you know they're there
they're doing their police stuff doesn't
mean that they can stop all the crime
ava you know this about the the formula
that's in europe versus the formula oh
yeah the reason why the formula is so
bad here is because of the government i
mean you see the ingredient this they're
totally different yeah like what's in
here in it here i don't know where
you're feeding your baby corn syrup
solids really bad a lot of soy very
strange do you know the top of your head
what the ingredient some of the
ingredients are right it was a lot of
soy yeah and what what was like canola
oil and something yeah
corn syrup corn syrup yeah corn syrup
that was it yeah one of the crazy things
is that
baby foods have too much salt in them
because parents taste it to see if it's
good yeah and adults can't taste as well
as a kid can so they're like oh that's
good you know and salty and then they
give their babies too much sodium hmm oh
man
well hair thin watch out
there is an issue i suppose in that we
have built the civilization off of these
these technologies like formula
like petroleum fossil fuels and things
like that and then when it comes about
that you can't get them for whatever
reason we're going back to the dark ages
we're going back to the way things were
i don't look at that and think the
solution is government i look at that
and say human society and civilization
was unable to get to that point but when
you can see the government actually
impeding you're like
actually we probably would continue to
grow and
and thrive were it not for the
intervention of this harsh regulation
that's uh that's true that's an
interesting point i remember when this
first happened i wrote about it because
i was like my first thought was not we
need the government to step in and save
us my first thought was how did my
great-grandmother do this because they
did right she would breastfeed and if
you can't you would get like a wet nurse
some women can't for whatever reason um
and if you adopt a child we want to
encourage adoption so you need to figure
out a way to get around that so they
would use wet nurses they would use
these other different kinds of milk but
at no point did they say we need a
government agency to step in and make
this happen
who is this woman i don't remember but i
saw something on twitter it was a woman
who tweeted about this she said like oh
what why don't we you know breastfeed
more oh yeah
yeah yeah but like crazy like as if it
was the most scandalous thing to suggest
well yes but there is
i feel like there's a lot of guilt
assigned to women who aren't able to
breastfeed to the point where it just
feels like they're being attacked and
they have a very emotional response as
women tend to do so it's like uh they
view it as very much like a person
that's obviously very sad but i mean the
way that that woman was like destroyed
for just you know just one tweet i was
like okay okay so
with the formula i think it's
interesting people have have pointed out
that not all women can breastfeed right
and okay so what would what would we do
in the past what nurses so one woman who
was producing too much would the baby
would you know get nourished from her i
suppose it's kind of crazy thought when
you realize that we have to use a
technology to feed our babies well
that's like one thing conservatives
won't admit is that the industrial
revolution in its essence actually
weakened the family unit throughout the
west
but conservatives don't want to have
that conversation usually about the free
market but yeah i think think about the
future what the future is going to be
like be i i mean i think
where we're headed now right now is a
future where no one breastfeeds at all
for a variety of reasons
you don't even have to carry the baby in
your own womb anymore with ectogenesis
so exactly we've talked about that
artificial wombs that are coming yeah so
china and and you know what the crazy
thing is i hear from the left this is
what they were tweeting at me i said you
know why kill the baby because the
democrats were you know i don't want to
rehash the whole abortion thing but
democrats wanted to pass an
abortion up to the point of birth for
the health of the mother if the baby's
viable and like that's the question the
babies viable can survive why kill it
and when uh on twitter i tweeted about
this some of the responses i got was why
should a woman have to destroy her body
and then i was just like that's
interesting that's how you see it that's
that way yeah they view it as destroying
your body
it's like i don't know there's like a
bunch of women who've had like five kids
and they're fit and their bodies are
just fine right does time also destroy
your body yes i mean yes then yes yeah
yeah you need government legislation on
time that's right yeah oh yeah restrict
it now yes motion will slow that's
that's all
health care is a really good example of
what i'm trying to convey with this idea
and it's that there was a story i think
was out of atlanta where a kid had a
genetic disorder and there was a cure a
genetic therapy that cost a million
dollars per treatment
and so the family was like the state
should pay for it and the state was like
we cannot give a million dollars for one
kid because what are we gonna do give it
to everybody we can't afford that
the issue is the medicine now exists
because it's created and these people
say therefore we deserve it
that's fascinating so my response to a
lot of these people who say healthcare
is a human right i'm like let's say you
have a disease that has no cure
you just resign yourself i suppose the
fact you have no cure
but then all of a sudden someone invents
a cure through hard work through heavy
investment and now it's a right now you
are
that's crazy to me that would be like
saying cell phones are a human right
technology that doesn't exist you have
no right to but as soon as someone
invented it it's your right that makes
no sense like i'm hungry so your food is
my right like that's not we've obviously
decided that's not the way society works
so this is this is the ultimate problem
i see uh i shouldn't say the ultimate
problem but this is a big problem i see
with modern politics in that a lot of
what you hear from the left is
something exists therefore it's my right
then i'm like bro that didn't exist for
our parents
like there there's cure for disease
cures for diseases today that there were
no cures for 30 years ago no one went
around being like i i should have a
right to have that disease cured and
they'd be like there's no cure what are
you talking about you have no there's
nothing someone invents it
so i suppose like the issue is
if we all come together and put billions
of dollars in investment and big
companies to invent one cure who gets it
yeah i mean whoever can fund the
development of it yeah but people on the
left
often will just look at the world it's
not just about medicine it's about every
aspect of it
i have a right to what currently exists
period you don't you can work for it you
can try and earn it some things have
gotten cheaper look poor people i tell
you this man poor people today live
better than rockefeller did they got
refrigerators they got air conditioning
they got clean running water
battled better dental care than than the
ultra wealthy back 120 years ago i think
that you do want to make sure people get
their needs met at the very least
because otherwise then they go towards
might is right and they'll seize control
or take the goods for themselves by
force and that doesn't work either yes
but listen listen then you've got to
have the i mean then if you're talking
about the government coming in is that
but
we're talking about hungry malicious
stepping
in your land's mind now everything's a
need all right
when before the era of formula
you couldn't feed your baby you couldn't
feed your baby you have a need you need
food for your baby too bad what are you
gonna do you got your your wife didn't
produce enough milk hopefully he's a wet
nurse
now that formula exists it becomes a
need like you the baby always needed
food but we created a way to sustain
that so oh yeah technology at first
cell phones were a great thing they made
your job easier
now you have to have one you can have a
job unless they can get in touch with
you you have an email account email used
to be a luxury some people didn't think
it would catch on that's interesting
about basic needs food shelter
transportation maybe is one food and
shelter because as you invent new types
of shelter then people feel like those
are part of their basic needs that i
need that now i need that solar powered
house because that's
well look my shelter that's that's
that's just taking ava around los
angeles a couple days ago and we were
going if anyone was in la you know the
grove and there's a market called arowan
over there which is just a horrible
horrible place but so fancy so fancy
just terrible 20 bucks a smoothie not
worth it yeah and it's like in la you
have a society that's very decadent
that's built on like okay if i have some
more money i can go this kind of store
and if i have even more money i go to
this type of grocery store and so then
those type of people feel like okay well
now i need this organic grass-fed
chicken that gets to poop 20 miles away
from another chicken right they feel
like they need that and so it's like how
do you stop where it's like this is a
need and this is a want how do you
define what each one is well once once
you get to the point where technology is
utilized by everybody it becomes normal
now today if you got a job somewhere and
didn't have a cell phone they'd be like
this is ridiculous it's so inconvenient
to get a hold of you the norm is to have
a phone right now it's now it's a need
so over time everything becomes a need
when we invented baby formula it was
like oh thank heavens now i can feed my
child you know if like the mother's not
nursing
now you need to have it because so many
kids are able to survive they exist now
yeah this is the definition of a success
problem because in the past we had
infant mortality rates that were
absolutely through the roof it was a
huge problem and for you know a culture
that says that we don't want more people
we sure do everything in our power to
make sure that
babies can survive which i think is
great i think that any sufficiently
advanced society absolutely should be
pointed in the direction of making sure
that the youngest most vulnerable
members of society live better but you
had you had more in for mortality but
people would also have way more kids
yeah i mean some people would have like
seven or eight kids and if two of them
died that was just how i win you had
population growth now you look at the
west and our populations are dying yeah
i mean we're way below the what we're
supposed to be having sustainable i mean
russia is going to have like 60 of its
population dropped by the year 2100 wow
the crazy thing to me is the idea of
these women these millennial men being
like it destroys your body and it's just
like that's how you view it is a crazy
thing it's a pure decadence yes is it
because the babies are bigger because of
the diet more like bovine growth hormone
and stuff in the diet yeah basically
babies seriously maybe so the babies are
big and it's really hard on women
because we're so gosh darn smart really
big heads this is why infants are [ __ ]
babies and children need care for so
long it's because their brains they're
first of all their heads are incredibly
unwieldy for them to hold up and we can
barely squeeze them out as it is if they
were to develop in the womb any longer
we wouldn't be able to give birth and we
would just go extinct so it's again
that's the definition of success problem
because we are so smart we have to they
develop outside the womb so much longer
than something like a baby elephant that
literally hits the ground running and
can now get away from predators so
humans are we're in a different class we
have much
different sets of problems to deal with
thankfully we're equipped with iq i
think we're going to survive
hope so thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you